Hey youtubers it’s charlie and since Winter
Soldier is getting ready to premiere I thought
it would be fun to talk about other big Captain
America stories they could do for the third
movie in phase 3.
Right now Marvel hasn’t announced a release
date but they have hired the same directors
from Winter Soldier to start developing the
movie.
There’s been a lot of big Marvel news this
week with the new Guardians of the Galaxy
Trailer so in case you missed it I’m bookmarking
Tuesday’s as like a permanent Marvel Video
Day.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything!
The story of Captain America 3 will have to
tie in with all the other films happening
in Phase 3 like Ant-Man, Thor 3 and Avengers
3 but here are the top 5 Captain America comic
book stories they could use.
Number 5 - Dimension Z written by Rick Remender.
It more of a science fiction based story that
involves this alternate dimension plot that’s
a little bizzare, but Kevin Fiege said that
Phase 3 is all about Magic and that opens
the door to the Multiverse.
Another big part of the story is Cap raising
Arnim Zola’s son as his own and even being
possessed by Zola for a little while.
Minus the multiverse aspect of the story,
they could totally use Red Skull’s daughter
Sin or Zola’s son in a new movie.
Marvel even based their Fear Itself comic
book on Sin.
Number 4 - Operation Rebirth.
Captain America is forced to work with The
Red Skull to defeat Hitler.
In the comic, Hitler’s consciousness was
trapped in the cosmic cube or tesseract as
it’s called in the movies.
So based on the events of the first Captain
America movie, they’d probably swap Hitler
for the Red Skull.
And swap the Red Skull for another villain
like Arnim Zola.
There are a lot of rumors that The Red Skull
is going to be in Winter Soldier, but pending
that we still don’t know what happened to
him after he got sucked into the tesseract
in the first movie, so the character is still
alive until proven otherwise.
Number 3 - Crossbones and Sin.
Captain America VS The Red Skull’s Daughter.
This story is all about how Crossbones played
by Frank Grillo in Winter Soldier tracks down
the Red Skull’s daughter Sin and the two
wreak havoc for Captain America.
There is a big rumor that Emily Van Camp is
secretly playing Sin in Winter Soldier, but
using the Sin character would give a third
movie a way to bring the Red Skull back full
circle.
Plus we’re already confirmed to see Crossbones
so most of the characters will have already
appeared in a Marvel movie.
Number 2 - The Death of Captain America.
This would have to be tweaked just a little
because it heavily involves Iron Man and Robert
Downey Jr only has a contract to appear in
Avengers 2 and 3 right now.
So using him again would be extremely expensive.
But they could substitute that character for
another hero.
It was the climax of the Civil War storyline
and would be a good story for Chris Evans
to leave the franchise on, based on what happens
to Captain America at the end of the story.
But since Evans is signed for at least 3 or
4 more movies, he’ll be around for a long
time.
And Number ` - Captain America Reborn.
This involves the resolution of the Death
of Captain America story and the Sharon Carter
character.
Since she’s being played by Emily Van Camp
in Winter Soldier we might get a few teases
from these storylines.
But Reborn is all about him coming back from
the dead with this supernatural Red Skull
body possession plot.
It’s very magical slash metaphysical, so
it would fit with the tone of phase 3 maybe
after a Doctor Strange movie.
And one last Bonus Option - Avengers Under
Seige.
This is all about Baron Zemo and the Masters
of Evil storming the Avengers Mansion and
beating everyone within an inch of their life.
They crush Cap’s spirit by destroying all
his World War II mementos from before he got
the Super Soldier Serum.
It’s just villains twisting the knife in
his wounds.
You’d have to substitute some of the Avengers
for other characters, but Winter Soldier is
already playing with this theme a little as
the villains injure Nick Fury pretty badly
in the movie.
There are a bunch of other possibilities for
them to pick from but remember that all of
Marvel’s Phase 3 movies thematically have
to blend well with the idea of Magic and tie
into the Infinity Guantlet storyline for Avengers
3 purposes.
Just picture Captain America in outer space.
The real trick is integrating the more cosmic
elements of the Marvel Universe into the more
practical aspects of the Captain America character.
So let me know which other stories you’d
like to see them do for Captain America 3
and do you think Red Skull will show up in
Winter Soldier?
I haven’t totally decided what my next Marvel
Movie video is going to be but be sure to
subscribe to get it and leave me suggestions
in the comments.
Right now click here for my Guardians of The
Galaxy character breakdown and click here
for my Winter Soldier Trailer Breakdown.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!